l'ordre règne en argentine après son
expulsion bernard henri henri lévy
témoigne renaud rupture des négociations
lock out de trois jours à flins tchad
deux escadrons de la légion étrangère au
secours de l'armée tchadienne pour
encercler les rebelles du frolinat zaïre
les parachutistes du 2e rep regagne la
france mercredi 7 juin
un monsieur bonsoir une bonne partie de
la france à ce soir le coeur en
argentine depuis soixante-quinze minutes
les tricolores engagés en effet leur
premier match de coupe du monde contre
les italiens alors tout de suite le
point du match alors que la deuxième
mi-temps a déjà repris depuis un quart
d'heure tout juste dose usa c'est le
score après 70 minutes de jeu c'est
pourtant l'équipe de france qui revenu
l'honneur de marquer le premier but de
cette coupe du monde cela de la première
mini à la suite d'allégations de
bertrand demanes dans l'espace bar à 6
kg d'or tous les défenseurs italiens et
centre pour l'acompte qui crée de la
tête regardons calvados et la premier
league dans la première mine
voilà la fille de nouveau ce but
le débordement de 6 et bernard lacombe
qui prend le meilleur sur le défenseur
italien à bellucci
mais ce but ça nos trop rapidement
marqué va déconcentrer les joueurs
français qui après avoir été dominés
pendant 25 minutes d'attenté c'est à
dire que pour entrer par john tibet
c'est finalement cas aux yeux des
dialyses et de trois reprises
au ralenti le coup franc de james dix
les trésors et lobé cabrini récupère le
ballon sur l'ailé gauche et centre pour
bettega la barre renvoi et cas aux yeux
remet les deux équipes à égalité
et puis donc il y a eu un troisième but
mais cette fois ci pour les italiens en
tout début de deuxième mi-temps donc 2-1
pour l'instant pour les italiens mais à
tout moment bien sûr nous vous informons
des modifications du score pendant ce
journal nous ferons de toute façon le
point à la fin du match est à dire à
20h30 avec tous nos envoyés spéciaux là
bas et pour ceux qui sont vraiment
fanatiques en peine de vous offre un
joli programme ce soir
la retransmission en différé de france
italie à 22h40
et puis à 00h10 dans la foulée et en
direct cette fois argentine en hongrie
un match qui nous intéresse au premier
chef puisque les deux équipes seront les
prochains adversaires de la france
ça c'est pour l'argentine côté sport
mais le choix du journal d'antenne 2 et
de ne jamais oublier que l'argentine ce
n'est pas que ça nous a paru encore un
témoignage aujourd'hui avec une
manifestation de femmes argentines au
moment même du coup d'envoi du premier
match du mondial une centaine de femmes
de tous âges ont défilé comme elles le
font chaque jeudi devant le palais
présidentiel pour demander des nouvelles
de membres de leur famille enlevés ou
disparus
eh bien les images que vous êtes en
train de voir nous ont été adressées par
des équipes étrangères
l'équipe d'antenne 2 qui était en effet
sur place présente n'a pu transmettre
son reportage
richard dio était en train de monter son
film à buenos aires quand une dizaine de
policiers en uniforme ont fait irruption
dans la salle de montage et l'ont
interdite et empêcher de transmettre ce
reportage par la liaison directe que
nous avons chaque jour entre buenos
aires et paris
c'est pour ça que nous avons utilisé la
liaison de tf1 l'intersyndicale des
journalistes et la direction de
l'information d'antenne 2 ont élevé une
très vive protestation
la veille dix la direction de
l'information d'antenne 2 cette équipe
que vous avez vu cette équipe dirigée
par richard dio avait pourtant reçu du
général merlot le président du mundial
l'assurance de pouvoir travailler
librement et antennes de demande par
ailleurs à lieu
bd les journalistes à exercer leur
métier à l'abri de toute censure er et
l'organisme il centralise tout c'est
toutes ces communications entre
l'argentine et l'europe n'est pas le
premier incident auquel les journalistes
sont confondus il ya aussi laventure
dont a été victime bernard henri lévy
bernard henri lévy était allé à buenos
aires quelques jours avant l'ouverture
du mondial pour assurer la couverture de
l'événement pour plusieurs magazines et
bien il a été incarcéré dès son arrivée
est expulsé quelques jours plus tard en
fait pas vraiment expulsé mais n'ont
pratiquement genève et paris je n'ai pas
été expulsé sur cette histoire n'a pas
grand intérêt et je crois qu'elle ne
pèse pas bien lourd à côté du martyr du
peuple argentin aujourd'hui bon j'étais
arrêté à l'aéroport
effectivement le fouiller questionner
interrogé pendant plusieurs heures
et puis bon une chose que je tiens à
préciser d'ailleurs c'est que la presse
ici a dit que j'avais été assigné à
résidence ce qui est faux ça n'est pas
vrai quand vous allez en prendre au bout
de six jours votre présence au bout de
quelques jours et non un certain nombre
de signes qui dans ce genre de pays ne
trompe pas m'ont fait comprendre qu'il
valait fait mieux que je rentre à paris
bon cela dit ce n'est pas ça l'important
l'importance que j'étais parti en
argentine pour essayer de voir et de
rendre compte de l'autre face du mundial
c'est-à-dire l'argentine de la torture
c'est à dire l'argentine de la terreur
c'est à dire l'argentine des camps de
concentration qu'est ce que vous avez pu
en voir
j'en ai vu beaucoup de choses j'ai reçu
le témoignage par exemple d'un père qui
a vu sa fille mourir il ya quelques mois
dans des conditions tout à fait atroce
que je raconte demain à l'observateur
d'ailleurs une jeune femme à qui on a
introduit un rat dans le vagin et qui en
est morte dans des dans des convulsions
et des souffrances terribles
j'ai eu le témoignage et le d'autres
types de témoignages de témoignage d'un
d'un petit tortionnaires un petit
tortionnaires qui depuis deux ans
circule de centres de torture en centre
de torture parce que dans ce pays la
bonté il ya une espèce de rotation comme
ça des descentes des tortionnaires et
éthérée qui m'a raconté comment ça se
passait aussi du point de vue d'un
tortionnaire
ce camp de concentration généraliser car
c'est ça aujourd'hui l'argentine si vous
voulez je crois que on ne comprend rien
à ce qui s'y passe si on ne comprend pas
que c'est d'abord une espèce de terreur
généralisée csg en vain la rue vous
paraît vraiment scandalisés un dock un
public et non pas ce qu'il ya sur de
tous les jours oui impliqués bien
entendu je crois qu'il n'y a pas un
argentin aujourd'hui à buenos aires qui
n'est pas proche de lui son voisin son
père sa mère son cousin son cousin
éloigné quelqu'un qui a été touché de
près ou de loin par la torture et
pourtant les voix touchante et dans les
stades de football et ne rien dire
pratiquement journaliste effectivement
parce que ils sont terrorisés moi j'ai
rencontré un nombre considérable
d'argentins de la rue acquis lorsque je
leur posais la question c'est quand
c'était vachement un chauffeur de taxi
il me demandait de descendre quand
c'était un serveur il s'éloigne et
immédiatement
ça s'appelle la terreur il ya un exemple
encore plus net j'ai eu quelques
contacts avec un industriel à buenos
aires qui est d'ailleurs proche du
régime et qui le jour de mon départ
considérant sans doute qu'il en avait
trop dit qu'il s'était peut être
compromis qu'il avait sans doute été
suivis par des policiers argentins car
la police est partout m'a fait une
demande que je trouve bouleversant on
m'a donné il m'a confié une fausse
interview de lui une interview il fait
l'éloge de videla une interview il dit
que la torture c'est bien une interview
où il couvre le régime et il m'a dit
avec un espèce de sourire un peu un peu
bouleversant comme ça vous savez garder
ça ça peut toujours ces derniers et
l'évier on va vous dire et on vous a
déjà dit que votre protestation a
peut-être un petit peu quelque chose de
dérisoire qu'elle est trop intellectuel
et que vous faites en quelque sorte je
joue avec la révolution voulez exporter
un peu partout coût des premiers points
jounée je ne veux pas exporter la
révolution j'ai jamais prétendu une
chose pareille ce qui me paraît urgent
aujourd'hui c'est de défendre la cause
des droits de l'homme partout ils sont
violés aujourd'hui en argentine il ya
15000 hommes et femmes qui sont disparus
dont on n'a aucune nouvelle
ces droits de l'homme c'est vrai en urss
c'est vrai en argentine serre en
argentine et en hongrie à propos du
match qu'on verra tout à l'heure et moi
je dis que des protestations
individuelle du type de la mienne ou du
type de celle de marek halter qu'a lancé
la campagne pour le boycott ici et du
type de celle d'une foule
d'intellectuels sont importants sont
importantes si elle se conjugue alors il
y vit merci de votre témoignage
deuxième fait de chapitre de l'actualité
ce soir l'afrique le chat très
précisément avec cette information nous
avons appris ce matin la participation
de plusieurs centaines de soldats
français
trois cent des ministres la défense à
une offensive des troupes
gouvernementales contre le frolinat tu
une colonne de rebelles a été mise hors
de combat 500 km de la capitale djamena
elle a été encerclée par les tchadiens
et par les troupes françaises appuyées
par dix avions jaguar encerclé dans une
palmeraie tout à fait encaisser dans des
falaises et de ce fait ils l'auraient de
très nombreux morts chez les rebelles
pas de perte en revanche dans les deux
escadrons français qui appartiennent au
1er régiment étranger de cavalerie et au
régiment d'infanterie de chars de marine
dans une vaste région désertique le nord
du tchad
la rébellion au gouvernement central de
djamena persiste depuis plus de 15 ans
dès l'indépendance accordée par la
france en 1960 des tensions très vives
étaient apparues entre les populations
du nord et du sud du pays
le nord du tchad bordée par la libye à
une population fortement islamisé
opposés aux populations du sud jusqu'à
son assassinat en 1975 le président
tombalbaye dont le régime était détesté
avait fait appel à l'armée française
pour mater serbe et lyon tous bouts et
frolinat soutenu par l'algérie puis par
la libye un accord de coopération
militaire existait entre les deux pays à
ce titre les légionnaires et les
parachutistes français
assurer la sécurité du pays après avoir
pris le pouvoir en 1975 le général
malloum demandé le départ des troupes
françaises
mais incapables de mater les rébellions
du nord ils réclamaient à nouveau
l'intervention de la france c'est au
titre de ces accords militaires que près
de 1800 soldats et coopérants français
opèrent aujourd'hui au tchad
l' affaire fait grand bruit dans les
milieux politiques français l'opposition
proteste violemment cela a commencé dès
ce matin à l'occasion de la
traditionnelle séance consacrée aux
questions orales à l'assemblée et qui en
principe n'entraîne aucun débat le
communiste jacques khalid a demandé au
président de séance bernard stasi un
scrutin public pour suspendre la séance
de façon à permettre au gouvernement de
s'expliquer sur cette intervention au
tchad et le républicain emmanuel hamel
s'en est pris à l'attitude des
communistes je vous laisse voir cette
passe d'armes
où sont les ressortissants français
alors les choses doivent être claires
actuellement nous appelons à reprendre
le combat contre le colonialisme je
demande au nom du groupe communiste et
mon collègue boca et moi même sommes
prêts à ne pas défendre nos questions
orales un scrutin public pour une
suspension de séance permettant au
gouvernement de venir s'expliquer sur la
nouvelle intervention qu'il fait au
tchad les frères aux relations avec les
peuples d'afrique
la somme des trois groupes de la
majorité alors que je ne parle comme mon
nom personnel se posera votre prétention
qui compte une fois de plus à prouver à
la france entière qui pourra faire le
constat une fois de plus les
interventions du parti communiste en
matière de politique étrangère
sa ligne avec prétention de la russie
soviétique
finalement cette demande des communistes
a été repoussée par 282 suffrages contre
198 le pc a appelé les parisiens a
manifesté lundi contre la politique
africaine du pouvoir françois mitterrand
trop côté qui se trouvait à epinal
aujourd'hui sans les lui aussi très
vivement pris au gouvernement
je vous laisse entendre sa réaction je
pense qu'aucun accord d'assistance
technique y compris les accords
d'assistance technique militaire
n'autorise la france intervenir dans les
conflits intérieurs dans les
compétitions politiques dans les
rivalités ethniques qui touche tel et
tel pays du monde et notamment tel ou
tel pays 2
rick donc même dans le cas de l'accord
d'assistance technique militaire
il ne peut pas y avoir à mes yeux et aux
yeux du parti socialiste intervention
armée de la france dans des conflits en
interne via je trouve indigne de la
france que pour soutenir je ne sais quel
dictateur on considère que nous sommes
en campagne avec une armée française qui
protège 600 toubous et les anéantit je
trouve cela triste pour notre pays ou
alors il faut que le gouvernement
explique au pays qu'il s'agit d'une
stratégie internationale qui exige
l'ensemble des pays du monde qui ont
plaisir préserver la paix la justice et
équilibre mondial en discute ça va donc
ce qu'en pensent ces socialistes les
communistes et le giscardienne il nous
manquait le point de vue des colis sont
aussi ceux nous allés interroger maurice
couve de murville actuel président la
commission des affaires étrangères à
l'assemblée et qui avant de s'exprimer
sur le fond a d'abord paru surpris dans
quelques secondes elles mentent en
interview le mans je vais à 12 degrés
par les journaux et je dois vous dire
que j'ai été très surpris parce que je
ne pensais pas que notre action au tchad
puisse aller jusque là
c'est à dire jusqu'à des opérations
militaire proprement dite qui sont
relativement importante et nous nous
prenons l'initiative
je croyais qu'il y avait des accords il
ya n'y a pas d'accord de défense yann
accord de coopération avec le chat
c'est-à-dire un accord qui nous engage à
envoyer des instructeurs là-bas pour
instruire les hommes et pour l'entretien
du du matériel mais ceci exclut toute
participation des opérations militaires
alors nous savions à moi je savais en
tous les cas que hanger de la
coopération il y avait quelques unités
ils ont quelques centaines d'hommes qui
avait été envoyé à une jeune emma pour
défendre la ville le cas échéant et y
compris des jaguars mais je ne pensais
pas que cela pouvait aller jusqu'à
entreprendre très loin de ne jamais
à des opérations militaires de
l'importance de faire qui nous sont
annoncés
il me semble que la france cherche un
peu à attirer les états unis dans son
jeu ou à s'abriter ou à s'abriter
derrière eux
ou alors demandé une aide logistique
comme on dit en d'autres termes à aa
donné l'impression que la france et les
etats-unis coopèrent dans ces questions
et évidemment il ne peut pas ne pas en
résulte est là la conclusion que surtout
si on y juin comme ça se fera lundi à la
conférence qui est annoncé d'autres pays
de l'europe occidentale ça ne peut pas
ne pas donner un peu l'impression qu'on
cherche à faire entrer les affaires
africaines dans un cadre atlantique dans
le cadre de l'alliance atlantique ce qui
évidemment est quelque chose de tout à
fait nouveau dans la politique française
ces causes de merville qui disait ce
matin que les troupes françaises
stationnées au zaïre devaient être
rapatriés hôpitaux et bien on apprenait
ce rapatriement officielle par un
communiqué de l'elysée dans l'après midi
le rapatriement de ce détachement
militaire ou chabat est prévue pour la
semaine prochaine à partir du 7 juin et
le présent république a demandé qu'à
l'occasion de ce mouvement des vivres et
des médicaments soient apportées aux
curieux aux populations éprouvées de la
région de coloris c'est d'ailleurs cette
population très traumatisée que le
président mobutu a rendu visite ces
dernières heures pour essayer de
rassurer européen les ayons notre envie
spécial françois cornet était là tout le
corps consulaire était présent sur
l'aéroport de lubumbashi pour accueillir
le président mobutu au chabat après son
voyage en europe au maroc et au sénégal
les consuls belges français grecs
italiens et américains représentent ici
4000 européen
cette visite du président zaïrois et
pour eux très importante car les
directives que le président va donner au
général zaïrois singa qui commande la
région de lubumbashi devrait rassurer
les européens dans les villes isolées de
likasi et de kipushi ou jusqu'à ce jour
les européens ne pouvaient quitter ces
villes sans laisser passer
laissez passer pratiquement impossible
d'obtenir et des européens travaillant
dans ces villes se sentait un peu les
otages aux mains de l'armée zaïroise le
président du zaïre est aussi venu à
lubumbashi pour décorer les officiers
des sous-officiers de la légion
étrangère de la plus haute distinction
militaire
hayward voilà je marque une pause très
rapide pour vous dire que france italie
toujours 2-1 pour l'instant mais de
l'impôt italien a ajouté que le quai
d'orsay a précisé aujourd'hui que 30
français étaient portés disparus au
zaïre tuées ou enlevées 30 français en
tout dont 6 coopérants militaires
troisième grosses têtes de chapitres
pour aujourd'hui
la greffe chez renault je vous le disais
hier soir tous ceux qui viennent sur
renault est vraiment à suivre et de fait
aujourd'hui la grève commencée à cléon
et à flins a fait tache d'huile
tour à tour les usines de douai de
sandouville de reuil d'orléans et
saint-ouen ont suivi le mouvement
la réaction de la direction n'a pas
tardé elle a été double d'abord la
suspension des négociations qui étaient
engagés depuis trois semaines
essentiellement sur l'évolution de la
carrière les ouvriers et puis surtout le
lock out
lundi mardi et mercredi à flins ou le
feu couvait déjà depuis deux bonnes
semaines
c'est ici dans l'atelier des grandes
presse de flins que la grève a démarré à
l'origine un incident de portée limitée
pour s'être présentait son travail avec
deux minutes de retard
un ouvrier est mis à pied pendant deux
jours les syndicats demandent la levée
de la sanction
la direction refuse grève puis
occupation de l'atelier le mouvement est
lancé
et depuis hier s'amplifie pour ces
ouvriers des presses une double série de
revendications 300 francs de salaire en
plus mais aussi et surtout de meilleures
conditions de travail et la possibilité
notamment pour ses os de devenir ouvrier
professionnel op 1
depuis 73 on a demandé le p1 audi avait
fait une grève de trois semaines en 73
depuis ce temps là on n'a rien alors là
je vois que les caméras des camarades
des lecteurs et moi on a demandé le gain
parce que vraiment oppresse les cadences
et puis tout ça c'est vraiment trop fort
les travailleurs de presse il pour
paresser tourner leur vie au point un
circuit porte encore ça alors et il y a
pas remis des travailleurs de presse ici
qu'ils ont des diplômes par exemple des
mécanos électriciens des mécanos
mécaniciens et ils ont électromécanicien
aussi il a il sent que vous préparez
pour une grève longue longue et durable
1 et on est solidaire on est tous
solidaires en bouche même ici un bon
coach ici on a des matelas on a des
sommets en à torrey télévision maman est
alors que dans cet atelier on s'organise
pour tenir longtemps
les débrayages se multiplient dans les
autres ateliers de flins et dans les
autres usines de la régie renault
revendications spécifiques des ouvriers
des presses s'ajoute maintenant des
revendications globales salaire minimum
de 3000 francs augmentation immédiat de
300 francs pour tous réduction du temps
de travail et 5e semaine de congés payés
dans ces conditions l'ensemble des
négociations qui s'ouvrait dans la
métallurgie est mal engagé des
négociations qui devaient porter sur le
revenu minimum minimum pardon annuel
garanti et sur l'aménagement du temps de
travail chez flaminaire reprise du
travail lundi l' usine de redon était
occupé depuis un mois fa mineur a été
repris par francine gomez le pdg de
waterman
on vient d'apprendre le déclassement de
la cité fleurie à paris c'est le conseil
d'état qui l'a décidé il s'agit d'un
ensemble d'habitations très pittoresque
en plein paris dont la sauvegarde
avaient entraîné il y a deux ans une
importante campagne d'opinion irruption
d'un groupe d'extrême droite dans les
locaux de notre confrère le monde vers
13h et qu'on fait ce faire mettre en
cause l'objectivité du quotidien et s'en
sont pris à des journalistes qui
tentaient de s'emparer de leurs
appareils photos l'un de nos confrères a
même été blessé
une initiative du sénateur caillavet le
parlementaire suggère que le prix omar
public qui jusqu'àlors avait seul le
pouvoir de décision en matière de droit
de grâce
et bien soit épaulé dans ce choix
difficiles par des magistrats élus le
cardinal marty condamne la venue de
monseigneur lefebvre dimanche à paris le
chef de file des traditionalistes entend
confirmer
dimanche 250 enfants à saint nicolas du
chardonnet bis à 20% d'euros sur 7 un
fruit et légumes comme les tomates et
fred les cerises
c'est la conséquence de la chaleur de
ces derniers jours mais on assure à
rungis que tout redeviendra normal dès
lundi d'autres nouvelles brèves
maintenant mais cette fois ci en images
avec laurent marti
attentat ce matin en plein centre de
madrid trois personnes ont été tuées
la femme de l'ambassadeur de turquie en
espagne son beau-frère et le chauffeur
du véhicule
trois jeunes gens ont tiré à bout
portant sur la voiture avant de prendre
la fuite
l'attentât a été revendiqué peu après
par un commando s'intitule en justice
contre les génocides arménien ce groupe
voudrait qu'ankara reconnaisse sa
responsabilité dans le génocide des
arméniens en 1915 et exige sa
condamnation officielle par l'onu
deux anglais retraités ont été retrouvés
hier soir assassinés dans leur maison de
mougins près de cannes
monsieur et madame moss ont été tués à
bout portant pendant leur sommeil
il semble pour l'instant qu'une seule
personne se soit introduit dans la
maison par la porte de la cuisine
demeurait ouverte
seul un petit coffre murale a été
emporté
le vol sont donc bien être le mobile du
crime mais les enquêteurs n'explique
toujours pas la sauvagerie avec laquelle
il a été commis
deux innovations le prochain calendrier
des vacances scolaires d'abord la
division en deux zones de la région
parisienne
d'un côté les académies de créteil et de
paris de l'autre l'académie de
versailles
deuxième innovation l'allongement de
trois jours le compte des congés de
février ce qui donne en détail tous un
du 28 octobre 2 novembre noël du 23
décembre au 3 janvier février onze jours
étalés sur quatre zones pack 13 jours
étalés sur deux zones vacances d'été
enfin le 29 juin
et j'ajoute que à portsall c'est
vraiment la désolation du mazout
s'échappant encore de l'amour qu'à 10
mais peut-être n'est-ce que de l'huile
de la salle des machines
pourtant ailleurs la vie renaît ainsi à
trégastel sur la côte de granit rose les
classes de mer ont repris leurs
activités
c'est dire qu'en de nombreux endroits
les plages sont revenues vraiment très
proches mais l'optimisme de chacun peut
être forcément raisonnée car ce pétrole
est vraiment tenace une exposition
insolite à neuilly dans la région
parisienne son thème la sécurité
industrielle et commerciale en fait ce
salon offre à un public averti et qui a
dû montrer patte blanche pour entrer ce
qui se fait de mieux en matière de
gadgets
tout ce qui peut servir à épier détecter
surveiller identifié neutralisent alerté
en quelque sorte le salon du prêt à
paray mais pas vraiment à la portée de
toutes les bourses
il faudra vous faire une raison les
gadgets anti rap sont très chers plus de
32 millions de centimes pour cette
mercedes blindées mais c'est du beau
travail
des vitres de trois centimètres
d'épaisseur à l'épreuve des balles
les tenues de protection non plus ne
sont pas donnés il faut compter entre
2000 et 3000 francs pour être protégés
de la tête aux pieds
la cour s'est mis au goût du jour les
gilets pare-balles deviennent de plus en
plus discret exemple ce gilet pour
femmes à déconseiller toutefois dont les
soirées l'ensemble mais c'est la
conséquence de la chaleur de ces
derniers jours mais on assure à rungis
que tout redeviendra normal dès lundi
d'autres nouvelles brèves maintenant
mais cette fois ci en images avec
laurent marti
attentat ce matin en plein centre de
madrid trois personnes ont été tuées la
femme de l'ambassadeur de turquie en
espagne son beau-frère et le chauffeur
du véhicule
trois jeunes gens ont tiré à bout
portant sur la voiture avant de prendre
la fuite
l'attentât a été revendiqué peu après
par un commando s'intitule en justice
contre les génocides arménien à ce gros
voudrait qu'ankara reconnaisse sa
responsabilité dans le génocide des
arméniens en 1915 et exige sa
condamnation officielle par l'onu
deux anglais retraités ont été retrouvés
hier soir assassinés dans leur maison de
mougins près de cannes
monsieur et madame hausses ont été tués
à bout portant pendant leur sommeil
il semble pour l'instant qu'une seule
personne se soit introduite dans la
maison par la porte de la cuisine
demeurait ouverte
seul un petit coffre murale a été
emporté le vol sont donc bien être le
mobile du crime
mais les enquêteurs n'explique toujours
pas la sauvagerie avec laquelle il a été
commis deux innovations le prochain
calendrier des vacances scolaires
d'abord la division en deux zones de la
région parisienne d'un côté les
académies de créteil et de paris de
l'autre l'académie de versailles
deuxième innovation l'allongement de
trois jours de cours des congés de
février ce qui donne en détail tous un
du 28 octobre 2 novembre noël du 23
décembre au 3 janvier février onze jours
étalés sur quatre zones pack 13 jours
étalés sur deux zones vacances d'été
enfin le 29 juin
et j'ajoute que à portsall c'est
vraiment la désolation du mazout
s'échappant cordes de l'amoco cadiz mais
peut-être n'est-ce que de l'huile de la
salle des machines
pourtant ailleurs la vie renaît ainsi à
trégastel sur la côte de granit rose les
classes de mer ont repris leurs
activités
c'est dire qu'en de nombreux endroits
les plages on re devenu vraiment très
proches mais l'optimisme de chacun doit
être forcément raisonnée car ce pétrole
est vraiment tenace
une exposition insolite à neuilly dans
la région parisienne son thème la
sécurité industrielle et commerciale en
fait ce salon offre un public averti et
qui a dû montrer patte blanche pour
entrer ce qui se fait de mieux en
matière de gadgets tout ce qui peut
servir à épier détecter surveiller
identifié neutralisent alerté en quelque
sorte le salon du prêt à paray mais pas
vraiment à la portée de toutes les
bourses
il faudra vous faire une raison les
gadgets anti rap sont très chers plus de
30 2 millions de centimes pour cette
mercedes blindées mais c'est du beau
travail
des vitres de trois centimètres
d'épaisseur à l'épreuve des balles
les tenues de protection non plus ne
sont pas donnés il faut compter entre
2000 et 3000 francs pour être protégés
de la tête aux pieds
la cour s'est mise au goût du jour les
gilets pare-balles deviennent de plus en
plus discret exemple ce gilet pour
femmes à déconseiller toutefois dans les
soirées l'ensemble mais qui dit
protection dit surtout détection et là
c'est l'électronique qui est reine pour
5700 francs vous pourrez vous procurer
cette valise anti rap digne de james
bond
si vous êtes enlevés elle émet des
signaux sonores et visuelles coup il ya
toujours les alarmes traditionnels
voilà la pluie avait fait son apparition
aujourd'hui sur les courts de roland
garros et le match entre patrice
dominguez et l'américain pisteur a dû
être interrompue à la reprise c'est
comme le français qui s'est qualifié en
4e manche en 7 6 5 7 7 5 et 6 2 autres
qualifications derrière moi les mecs and
sisters autre qualification celle du
mexicain ramirez aux dépens de l'italien
à zouk rnb quant à porte
il a été écrasé par tanner 6 3 6 0 6 1
pour un autre espoir français en
cyclisme maintenant cinquième étape du
dauphiné libéré vainqueur christian 16
mecs
au classement général pas de changement
maurice le guilloux conserve sa place de
leader
la météo maintenant un temps ensoleillé
et lourd aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble du
pays avec sur toutes les régions des
orages parfois accompagnés de grêle les
températures étaient en hausse comme
vous le voyez et avoisiner les 27 degrés
dans l'intérieur
demain et bien demain du soleil et des
nuages sur l'ensemble du pays des orages
isolés éclateront à nouveau plus
nombreux d'ailleurs sur la moitié ouest
quant à dimanche c'est bien alternance
de nuages et d'éclaircies avec
possibilité de pluies orageuses sur
toute la france sauf une frange qui aura
vous le voyez de l'alsace aux régions
militaires n où régnera vraiment un
temps chaud et ensoleillé voilà pour ce
dernier journal ce soit n'y a pas de
dernier journal tout simplement en
raison de la coupe du monde je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de semaine
ils vont trouver lundi avec plaisir
bonsoir à tous bon week-end